so again my name is andres and i've been
doing all sorts of research in this
intersection of people and computing uh
the word i'm presenting today is um as
michael mentioned focus on trying to
understand more of the uh
the how people uh
kind of
exchange messages in uh online spaces in
crisis um and so kind of the way i
titled this this work is collaborative
news is kind of the broader theme and
i'm talking i'm going to be talking
about two things first is kind of a
study of a set of studies on how people
use social media in uh disaster or
respon um during war and then how do we
kind of get inspired by some of that
work to produce a couple of systems that
i'm gonna describe to you so it's a bit
about you know people and as well as
systems so i'm gonna start with the
narco tweets world that i described um
so first you know i want to acknowledge
a lot of the work that i'm presenting
today is a result of collaborations with
many different people in different
institutions um who are you know
instrumental in this work uh so just to
give you some background first um
i know when i
the context in which i'm doing this work
again is a mexican drug war and just to
give you some idea of the size of these
there's been more than 60 000 people
that have been killed uh by this
conflict and actually now the latest
number that i've seen is now is 90 000.
i started around 2006 when president
calderon took office and you know there
were a couple of different policy
changes that they introduced uh and that
created all sorts of you know mayhem in
in mexico um one of the interesting
things or you know and also very very
sad thing about the the drug war in
mexico is that the crisis that people
are exposed to are part of everyday life
so a lot of the work that we see
in crisis informatics from say alicia
palin and other people who have been
doing a lot of work in the space are
kind of these kind of big major events
like an earthquake or a hurricane or you
know the kinds of things that you may
experience maybe once twice in a
lifetime uh the kind of events that are
happening in mexico are really you know
every other day especially in some of
the cities that are uh you know battling
a lot of these issues with the drug
cartels so you have drug cartels
fighting with other drug cartels you
have uh the military trying to fight
some of these cartels and the local
police and you know law enforcement so
there's a very complex situation where
sometimes some of these local police are
kind of working with some of the cartels
and so it becomes a really complex space
um and if you were to think about you
know the way typically we respond to
emergencies say in the u.s for example
there are kind of a couple of actors
first is the government you know the
police department or the mayor or the
governor who will you know give a
statement of what's happening um
and then you have the media that is kind
of broadcasting that you know telling
the people what the government is is
finding what where you should go for you
know looking for shelter things like
that um
and these two entities kind of
collaborate in some ways you know
sometimes media finds information that
the government doesn't have but there is
this sort of collaboration and that's
how people get information about what's
happening in their community when
something an emergency happens
unfortunately in mexico that's not the
case
so for example here is this article from
the washington post that talks about how
journalists for example
are not reporting what's happening and
here i'm just going to read from this
quote it says you know fearing for their
lives and the safety of their families
journalists are adhering to a near
complete news blackout under strict
orders of drug smalling organizations
who dictate via daily telephone calls
emails and news releases what can and
cannot be printed or air so you have you
know if you're a journalist in one of
these cities uh if you you know there to
publish something of what's going on you
might get killed and in fact many
journalists have been killed uh because
of that uh so journalists cannot publish
what's happening and this blackout
extends to to the government as well so
again the same article says how
government officials in the city of
novolareda which is in the border with
texas how the mayor of that city
mysteriously disappears for days and
refuses to discuss
drug violence and even the military
general who presides over the soldiers
patrolling the cities the city does not
hold any news conferences so again in
mind you're a citizen in this in this
kind of cities and then you turn on the
tv and all you see are you know soap
operas or you know things that are not
related to what you see happening on the
streets uh so that's very disconcerting
uh so in parallel to these kind of laws
that we had from the news media and the
government uh one of the things that
we've seen is the increase of adoption
of you know internet technologies so
we've seen this in many different
countries as well as you know in the
past 10 years the number of users has
doubled uh and also as you would expect
you know social media adoption has
increased and twitter in particular is
uh you know quite one of the major uh
networks people use in addition to
facebook uh and actually is the fifth
largest country in twitter is mexico uh
so you have um
district these three things are
happening one is the increased adoption
of social media or just internal
technologies in general uh the weakening
of institutions like i mentioned you
know the the government uh the the news
media uh are not doing what they
typically do uh and then you have the
increased violence as a result of this
this war and so when you have these
three
things intersect one of the things that
we start noticing are things like this
uh this is a tweet that i found a few
years ago and i'm just going to
translate that to english
so this is a woman i changed the name
angela um she says you know caution and
gonzales avenue by the big supermarket
people report a recent risky situation
and then a hashtag mty follow so a
couple of things to note here one is the
um you know the mention of a place uh
the other one is uh this this term risky
situation or risk situation
and uh it's kind of a euphemism that
people use on twitter to refer to you
know granite attacks car bombs all sorts
of really terrible things are happening
um you know that that there are people
are experiencing the cities and the
other one is the the hashtag mty follow
so one of the fascinating things is that
a lot of these uh citizens in these
cities have developed a hashtag for
their city kind of organically so in the
case of monterey which is the city where
i i grew up uh mty is the code for the
city that you will find in like the
airport code for example and follow just
an invitation to follow so actually if
you go to twitter right now and you go
to search for mty follow you will see
like live reports of what's happening as
you know anywhere from like things like
this like a risky situation grenade
attack bomb all the way to things like
traffic and things like that uh what is
interesting is like the the hashtags
kind of emerge as a result of this news
blackout and they kind of now have
ground to encompass all sorts of things
um you know including again
things like traffic and so on um so i
was really fascinated by these sort of
messages that i started to notice you
know as a person who grew up there and
has family there uh you know i heard
from friends and family that bad things
were happening but they didn't know you
know where to find information and one
of the things that i learned from some
friends and family as well is that the
only way to find what's going on in the
city was to go to twitter and search for
this type of hashtag
and so i decided to look at four
different cities where you know violence
was particularly prevalent
monterrey which is the city that i was
describing it's a city of about four
million people
reynosa
the other one is veracruz and saltillo
so these four cities kind of represent
uh you know a sample of the cities that
that kind of are primarily affected by
the violence and they you know they have
different degrees of internet
penetration etc but overall you know
they're kind of pretty active on on
social media and each one of them has
developed its own organic you know
hashtag like the one i mentioned uh and
so we basically looked over the course
of 18 months we grabbed all the tweets
that were produced by people and uh and
we wanted to understand what people were
doing uh so one of the things that you
know first thing i was trying to do is
you want to see
word frequency and i know this is uh
typically cons perceived as like the
worst way you can do uh visualization
but you know it's a it's a one way in
which i decided to you know start
looking at just what are the most common
words and now to me it's like a it might
not be the most useful um you know
device for research but it's actually a
good way for just seeing you know
visually what
kind of people are talking about so this
is from monterrey
and you know one of the the biggest work
here is balazera which is in spanish
means shootout or shooting uh and the
other thing that you notice here the
name of a user which i'll get back to
that and then the things like
detonaciones which is blast
percussion avoid and the names of
locations so if you are familiar with
the geography of the city guadalupe is
one of the kind of areas neighborhoods
garza is one of the main streets etc so
you really get to see kind of what i was
showing in the previous in the tweet you
know locations type of events and you
know like valacera and then mentions of
some users uh so we wanted to do a more
uh
analysis of what people were talking
about uh so one of the things that we
found and this is not just on twitter
there is this emergence of narco
language in the culture in mexico
so you know in the past few years as the
cartels have been becoming more and more
violent
there are kind of neologisms that people
have come up with to describe some of
these violent events so for example they
were encouraged which means uh finding a
body wrapped in a blanket so it's often
happens often enough that you know
there's a war for that now uh there's a
bunch of other ones like narco tunnel or
encounter which is the body in the trunk
of a car for example um and so we were
really interested in looking at these
this war as this this was as a way to
see whether they may correspond to some
of the violence that we were seeing uh
in
in the city and so we looked at a couple
of
the four cities that i mentioned and
you know one thing that we found is that
the the kind of presence and the
increase in decrease of this mentioning
of these words corresponded to to the
homicide data that we found from the
government and again a lot of the data
that we have here is really hard to get
like ground truth right because the
government obviously is trying to
minimize the the you know the what's
what they perceive is happening or
they're trying to say that nothing is
really happening but still this is hard
to you know avoid a lot of these to
counter or the the body so you know we
found some some positive correlation
there that may indicate uh that you know
what you find on twitter make or respond
to some of the violence that you see on
the streets uh the other thing that we
did is uh we looked at uh these four
series again
and you know we just wanted to see what
was the kind of the timeline and the
frequency and the spikes of of number of
tweets per per day uh so a couple of
things to note here the first one is you
know every spike that we found actually
corresponded to somewhat major events so
for example uh in reynosa uh around this
uh late november late in 2010 the
biggest spy corresponded to these
clashes that killed 47 people
in monterey this is one of one of the
most
violent days in the history of the city
52 people were killed by the cartels in
a casino and so you see that the spikes
you know and twitter activity correspond
to that and again you know trying to
show that perhaps there is some you know
relationship between what the the
activity that we see on twitter and what
we see on the streets as well uh the
other thing that we notice is the the
spread of this activity so if we look at
the geographic location of each one of
these cities
this is kind of going north to south and
that's actually how the violence has
spread as well in mexico so it started
in the border towns where you know a lot
of the drug trafficking is happening and
it spread south uh in terms of you know
for example the setas cartel which is
one of the most violent cartels has
spread that way and you know even gotten
all the way to central america now um so
again kind of the the bottom line and
one of the things you see here you know
like the activity in reynosa was you
know started to get high early in uh
2010 there was not much in monterrey but
then it started to increase and you see
again basically this this volume of
activity kind of moving north to south
um
so that was another thing that we looked
at uh and more recently one of the the
kind of
things that i noticed i've been
following this for a few years now and
one of the things that i noticed you
know early on when um when i talked to
people who lived there and and i read
the messages that were coming from
twitter we see this kind of sense of
panic in the messages so for example uh
early on one of the things that the
cartels did to show their strength is
that they will kill people they will
hang them and they will leave the the
bodies hanging from a bridge in like a
major revenue or something and so
obviously that will create a lot of
panic and people were passing by you
know in the middle of the day and seeing
this thing um and now when that happens
you know when i read the messages on
twitter um we see like people were
reporting this is more of an annual you
know like the way we report traffic here
like oh i can't believe this happened
again it's so annoying whatever but you
don't see this sense of panic anymore so
that was kind of more anecdotal evidence
that i was just kind of getting from
from twitter messages and from people
who i was talking to so i kind of wanted
to see whether there was some evidence
that we could find from the data that
may suggest that this indeed was
happening that people were losing
sensitivity to to the violence um so we
looked at the the literature in
psychology and there are like three main
um kind of variables the three main ways
in which you know in psychology people
measure effective desensitization um and
so we have this in more detail in our
chi paper but basically uh the the
models that psychologists have developed
predict an incre lowering negative
effect an increase in dominance which is
like some words that represent more
aggressiveness and increase activation
uh which is kind of how excited people
seem in these words so we use uh look
which is this database that uh some
people at ut uh university of texas
develop to kind of assess the value of
each one of these these variables on the
messages and we found that for each one
of these cities uh what the the kind of
psychological theories were predicting
we saw that happening as well on the
twitter data and so again you know um
twitter data is obviously biased towards
people who have smartphones or who have
access to computers and so on but we
even with all those constraints we still
found some evidence of this
effectiveness citization um and so
that's kind of confirming some of the
empirical some of the anecdotal evidence
that we were looking at um now the other
thing that i was really fascinated by is
you know who is tweeting about this kind
of things
so we looked at
the four different cities and try to map
individuals based on two things one is
the number of tweets that they were
producing with the hashtags for the city
and the number of followers that they
had so i'm just going to focus on one of
them here uh so again each one of the
circles is an individual um
so there are like you know just visually
uh you know one of these i found is that
for example who are these people who who
do you think this might be people who
have you know millions of followers but
have contributed very few tweets to the
conversation
yeah kind of like celery so cnn spanish
was one of them and actually what was
really interesting to me is that they
were using the hashtag that this kind of
citizens had come up with when they were
reporting the news about these cities uh
so obviously cnn in spanish you know
reports about anything that cnn in
english reports so uh but when they
reported about uh the violence which is
only in like major events they used the
hashtag that people had come up with uh
so they were mainly like these sort of
news organizations with millions of
followers or even celebrities too and
then you have like you know average
people and with you know uh
tens or hundreds of tweets that they
contributed with you know what i would
say just average number of followers and
then you have this other group of people
here which we're calling curators and
actually they were the most fascinating
group of people and so what what when we
looked at their activity and what they
were doing what's interesting is that
basically what you see is that people
are tweeting at them and then they kind
of broadcast some of those messages when
they confirmed them across multiple
different people and so
they not only have tons of followers
obviously not as many as cnn but they
have you know decent number of followers
and they're very important people in
these cities so if you want to know
what's happening in one of the cities
you actually follow some of these people
rather than following the noise on the
hashtag sometimes you just follow that
person yeah are those people
if the journalists are being pushed by
like what about these people yeah so
they are at risk and actually it's
really hard so i tried to talk to them
and i was able to talk to them at some
point they were always very cautious
they are using pseudonymous uh
identities
some of them have been targeted by the
cartels in particular there was this guy
who was running a blog not only on
twitter but he was present on twitter
and he was running a blog actually
he started as an account with a
male name but then he moved to an
account with a female name i don't know
if the owner of the block changed but
that person was targeted by the cartels
and at some point in it
it disappeared and so people you know
wonder whether he was killed or not uh
so there's been a couple of cases where
some of these individuals have been
killed or just disappear after they get
received threats
so they are they they tend to be very
careful but still um they're they're at
risk and one of the interesting things
that i find in this is that um
the journalists they obviously when they
publish a report on the newspaper they
put their name and all this uh these
people are you know pseudonymous on
twitter uh but even then they're at risk
um and
one of the interesting things that we
see is like even the journalists today
when they start reporting about this the
newspaper no longer puts the name of the
journalist they say editor for example
or sometimes they even quote twitter and
say on twitter people are reporting this
thing without saying anything that's the
newspapers approach sometimes um so yeah
there's definitely a lot of risk in
there are these cartels technically
savvy enough to like doxx people yeah
can they go after them figure out is it
yeah so actually when this started
happening when people on the internet
were being killed a lot of people in the
tech world in the u.s were like oh this
is a really easy problem to solve we
just use something like thor or whatever
right uh what turns out is that the
characters are not very sophisticated so
what they do is let's say that i see you
kill somebody and then i tweet about it
like hey michael kill somebody um you
know that i saw you and so you don't
really have to dox me or anything so
it's more like
via the
through the information that you're
reporting i can figure out who this
person is and what the cartels have is
they have a lot of power on the ground
so they can kill five people and maybe
one of them was the person they wanted
to kill so they don't care right so for
sure yeah
exactly yeah by the way feel free to
interrupt at any given point
yeah
um it seems like the cartels might want
a lot of the students to spread in order
to like reinforce their
might power some of this news to spread
in order to reinforce their power
yeah yeah actually one of the
fascinating things is that
one of the curator accounts that we were
following uh started to receive uh well
people started to be suspicious about
their activity and they were
basically so what you see a lot of these
accounts they receive messages from the
people on the ground saying hey i see a
convoy of cartel whatever and then they
aggregate all these messages and then
they retweet them or publish them one of
the accounts uh what they were doing or
one of the theories i don't have this or
not is that they essentially were
crowdsourcing the location of the
military and they were only interested
in the military and not in the kind of
cartels and so people started to be
suspicious about it and then they were
like hey seems like all the things that
you are all the information that you're
gathering and the kind of things that
you're retweeting back are only the
location of the military and so they
kind of started to respond like oh
that's not true we are doing this at
this and they eventually lost um
trust from the community they lost all
their followers and
basically the account closed and never
came back i mean maybe came back with a
different name but that's the kind of uh
there's some some degree of suspicion in
in all of these activities and there's
been also some rumors that some cartels
are spreading you know fear about
something happening and just to increase
the sense of uh you know urgency or so
this connects to some of the practices
that the cartels have which is
let's say that you're cartel a and you
control a city if you're cartel b and
you want to attack that cartel what you
do is you go into that city and start
killing people randomly so that the
military comes in and kicks out the
cartel that you were against and so part
of that strategy is also spreading fear
on social media
i haven't found a lot of evidence that
that's true but there's rumors of that
and obviously it's really hard to do any
i mean what we are doing here is just
like very simple workouts and things
like that so there's no way through what
i do that we could find that out but
there's definitely rumors of that
yeah
we have this other analysis that we did
of um the network of retweets and again
you know it's just to reiterate the the
people who we found being the curators
through the other methods also came out
to be the most kind of central people in
in the network of retweets um just
different methodology same kind of
finding um but one of the most
interesting things like i wanted to know
who these people were right i was
following them on twitter i was looking
at all their messages but you don't
really get to see or understand what
their motivations are you know and
trying to you know ask them why you do
what you do how do you get started all
this kind of information so i reach out
to a bunch of them obviously not many
replied to me um
but you know i was able to talk to a
couple of them
one interesting thing is that most of
them were women
or at least had women named in their
messages
so i'm just
using fictitious name on their already
fictitious names so this is two of them
angela and claudia so angela has about
25 000 followers uh she has tweeted
about 35 000 times and when i ask her
you know how many hours do you spend a
day on
curating information on twitter she's at
15 hours a day to me it was crazy like
how do you spend 15 hours a day
she didn't say what exactly she does for
a living but my impression is that she
has a kind of job where she can have you
know her twitter feed on one side and
then do her other work on the other side
of the screen um that's the only way
imagine she might be able to do this
and she's in her early 20s i was able to
talk to her on skype
claudia similar you know more followers
but about the same
um you know same range a lot more tweets
and when i asked her how many hours a
day she kind of laughed and she i mean
she kind of implied that she spends many
hours maybe even more than the 15 hours
and if you look at the number of tweets
you might suspect that she may spend
even more time doing this uh she didn't
say she didn't want to say how old she
is but again these are people are
spending a lot of time receiving
messages from people on twitter and kind
of broadcasting those that they consider
are valid and the way they do that is
very like ad hoc so they you know they
decide if five people who seem somewhat
legit are reporting the same event it
might be true and then they broadcast
that and some of them have gotten enough
recognition from the community that now
they give their kind of sms their phone
number to some people who they trust and
those people kind of send them messages
or they are sometimes able to call back
some friends or
people that they know in certain
neighborhoods to confirm whether what
they're reading or on twitter is correct
or not
uh the other thing that i wanted to ask
them you know how did you get started
you know i was really curious like do
they have this kind of civic intrinsic
you know motivation of like i'm gonna
help my community uh and actually it
turns out that that's not necessarily
true and so for example for angela she
said that she joined twitter just
because a friend told her it was cool um
and uh and for claudia she said that she
joined because she wanted to follow
celebrities um so you know either
friends or celebrities following that
was kind of like their main motivation
to to join twitter and and for example
for i don't know if it's chloe or angela
i think angela she mentioned how she was
just using twitter you know to chat with
a couple of friends she didn't have many
followers and it happened that one day
uh her uncle passed by after the very
first uh case of these people hanging
from a bridge and the uncle sent her a
photo of that and she tweeted that photo
and that's how she became like like at
that particular event she was the one
who had this this photo and information
about where and what
and that's what got her a bunch of new
followers and from then on she kind of
made it her mission to kind of be able
to aggregate this information and report
on it
the other thing that i asked you know
how do you see your role in this
community of twitter people um so angela
for example she says you know it is as
if i am a journalist as if i was a work
correspondent on the social networks
of the world we are living in mexico so
for her is very much about like thinking
of this role as a journalistic role uh
for claudia i was more like well she
said my role on twitter is that of yet
another journalist but one of the things
that she kept preferring throughout the
interview is that people think of her
like an angel and that you know she says
that you know when people leave home or
they leave work they often tweet at her
and say hey is it safe to go through
this part of the city and then she was
like yeah sure or not
and so actually that's one of the things
that we noticed on on twitter in general
that a lot of people are using it um
from interviews a lot of people are
using it as a the way you might check
the traffic here right when you are
going home you want to see what areas to
avoid people often check in interior
what's trending or what these curators
are reporting
and again kind of going back to what
michael was saying there is definitely a
certain degree of intimidation from the
cartels to these curators and this is a
photo of these two people
who were killed by the cartels
and this banner here says this is what
happens when you report things online
and so it was a clear you know attack on
on the people who were reporting things
online uh whenever these things happens
people are always suspicious about
whether these people actually were
reporting things online and maybe that's
just a way of you know killing two
random people that you were already
going to kill as a cartel person and
then just sending a signal
uh and actually what's interesting is
that also from the government
perspectives there's been some
degree of intimidation so this is the
case of these two twitter users who
were charged with terrorism for
retweeting
somebody's tweet
about some
rumor of kids being kidnapped in schools
so one of the cities that we that we
studied the city of veracruz uh one day
people started to report on social media
that there were cartels going to schools
kidnapping kids and so people were going
crazy and these two in particular
started to kind of agitate and say you
know this is really scary maybe there's
something happening uh but the governor
was actually at the same time tweeting
back at people and saying don't believe
those rumors they're false but the
government didn't have any reputation
built up uh throughout this uh few
months of violence and these people
actually had a lot of reputation online
and so
the governor was really upset about this
and they listed a bunch of accounts on
the government on the police website
saying we are going after them because
they're spreading rumors that are
causing people to be afraid and we're
going to charge them with terrorism and
so they were able to find two of the
like 17 accounts that they listed these
two people and they send them to jail
and obviously there was a lot of uproar
and people including an international
community kind of tried to help them and
get them out and eventually
i think amnesty international got
involved and they were freed um but what
was interesting is that
the the governor and this is a cartoon
that happened uh when this happened when
he introduced a new law that made it
illegal to post misinformation on
twitter and one of the challenges is
with a lot of the things that are
happening in mexico is that it's unclear
what counts as misinformation and so it
was very much up to the government to
define what that is and use the law in
that way so one of the things that
actually we are doing now trying to see
whether there is a chilling effect of
this law and you know some early results
suggest that there might be some we
looked at the accounts that were posting
things before and then we follow them
after the the introduction of this law
and we saw a decrease in the number of
tweets um it's a very difficult thing to
claim but you know that's one of the
things we're trying to figure out there
are better mechanisms to assess this uh
the the introduction of this law and
actually the law eventually was um
killed by the local congress so
that would be another thing to look at
um so one of the things that we're
interested in general is you know
this whole kind of experience looking at
what's happening in mexico has made me
become really interested in how might we
apply some of these into building
systems that might support this sort of
uh collective action online and so we
started with uh trying to think about
where we live in seattle and obviously
it was also a less risky place to start
building systems
so we were thinking is there a way of
kind of where there are no curators like
the ones we see in mexico are there ways
of aggregating this information at the
hyper local level at the level of a
neighborhood or at the level of a city
for example so in the case of seattle
there is enough density in in the tweets
that you can actually look at um
neighborhood based uh twitter reports or
kind of what's trending in a particular
neighborhood by looking at the twitter
data and so we have this system that is
currently running it's called hooli.net
uh that basically allows you to select
from a city it is all the cities around
king county not only seattle and then
select a neighborhood and then you get
to see what messages are being posted
related to the neighborhood
and this is very simple looking just at
keywords that match different things
really so each neighborhood has a kind
of a bag of words in some ways uh that
relate to that to that place and then
allows you to see what's what people are
talking about in that neighborhood uh
the other thing that we have is uh you
know kind of like a trending topics kind
of thing of what's happening in the
neighborhood where the most common
themes uh what are the most active
people you know in the case of mexico
those cute arrows personally will come
up um and then what are the places that
people mention etc uh so it's very much
uh
um you know a system design for this
particular city but you know there are
reasons to believe that this could be
extended to others and actually emad
here is uh looking at uh extending that
to new york as well um
so so that's one of the things that we
were looking at one of the the
challenges let me go back a little bit
um one of the challenges with this
automatic automatic way of doing things
is that there is obviously a bias
towards what's already on twitter right
so we are only able to surface events
that people report on twitter
but there is a lot of things that people
don't report on twitter and so we were
interested in looking at the kinds of
events that the local media used to
report or
a lot of local media at least in sierra
leone cities of the us is kind of dying
because there's not much money in local
reporting and so we were thinking about
are there other ways in which we can use
this sort of systems in a very athletic
you know dynamic way uh where maybe
twitter is not used but we could
crowdsource some of the production of
some of these
event reports that that are happening so
we created this system called newspap
that allows you to enter the name of an
event um like the zombie parade for
example in boston and it gives you a
couple of different like headlines
similar to what you will see on buzzfeed
or something like that
and so like the five things you missed
at the zombie parade um
and so
what it takes you after that is it takes
it to a page that looks like
let me see
like this
that is kind of like a google docs plus
um template
um you type the num the the name of your
um collaborator so this is very much
thinking about there is an event like a
zombie parade or a garage sale or
whatever and
there are other people who might be
there people that you know people who
may not be tweeting or may uh maybe
putting things on instagram or whatever
and allows you to collaboratively uh
create a report of the event in this
format of kind of again like buzzfeed or
huffington post approach of like very
much like a listicle like the five
things that you miss at this event as a
way to make a more of a playful way of
contributing to a document that reports
on what's happening in the city that may
not be produced either by local media or
by twitter users uh and here the reason
we're showing this to screens is because
it allows you to do this simultaneously
the same way you will do it on google
docs for example so it's very much like
thinking about how do we provide super
basic templates for multiple people to
produce event reports uh simultaneously
from our an event um
so there's again the basic things of the
system is there is a headline generator
uh you can embed media from any source
and you can have a text that represents
whatever you're reporting and you can
also add a request for improvement so i
can be like hey i know that michael
takes out some photos and he might be
you know at the event you know i can add
a little like placeholder in the
document saying hey michael could you
add a photo of the zombie that is
walking around whatever um so that's
kind of a thing that we were
experimenting with and one of the
challenges with this is obviously that
it only works when there are people
willing to contribute and there are
people at the event who happen to have a
phone or or the ability to to do this
kind of work and so it works in some
scenarios it didn't work in many others
again
depended a lot on the people who were
there so then we started to think about
other ways in which we can leverage
uh perhaps paid workers to at least
bootstrap some of this thing um so we
started to play with uh taskrabbit i
know how many of you have used
taskrabbit uh so taskrabbit is very
similar to mechanical turkish instead of
doing virtual tasks you do tasks on the
physical space
so we were thinking about like how do we
kind of use some of those uh the tool
like taskrabbit to
give people tasks to go to a place and
report on what's happening at that place
so we created this other system called
eventful and what eventful is it's
essentially a workflow system uh
what it does um is recruits people on
taskrabbit gives them like little tasks
like show up at the
you know downtown right now or in the
next hour and take a photo of the parade
that is happening there and just send it
back or you know or you can give them a
couple of different tasks as well and so
the system works like this so there is a
person a requester you can mine this
could be a blogger or a
journalist who wants an event report
and then
basically a lot of people are hired to
do this
small task of going to a place and
reporting those things and they could be
either volunteers or could be paid
workers so the system is agnostic to
that in some ways so if it's paid
workers it connects to the taskrabbit
api but if it's volunteers it simply
gives them a set of tasks
then there is a curator
which right now is a virtual uh
paid worker who receives all the
information that is coming from the
people in the ground and kind of
approves or rejects some of the content
based on quality uh that then a writer
kind of puts together in the form of a
story so this person is simply like a qa
person and then this person is the one
who actually produces this this kind of
document there's a lot of work already
in crowdsourcing you know how to produce
documents with lots of people so we
didn't really focus that much on this we
focus more on this aspect of what kinds
of tasks can we give to these people on
the ground
so the system works like this so when
you run an event report you go to the
system and you enter the name of the
event when it will happen at what time
uh and the address of it and what kind
of event it is and the the the type of
event determines the
um the sort of missions that are
produced so we have a certain
kind set of missions there um and then
so the the crowd workers on the field
receive a mission that is a more mobile
friendly mission thing so it's basically
a to-do list and so he says something
like take a photo of the festival booth
or ask another attendee what they liked
about the event et cetera so as you
perform some of these tasks some of them
require you to like take a photo for
example and it opens the um the ability
to take a photo and then sends the photo
back to the system and so you get to see
what you're doing what you need to be to
do and some of the tasks are bonus tasks
so sometimes we as
the curator start seeing the data that
is coming in they might see like oh we
need another photo of that or maybe ask
this other question so some of these
tasks come up there and there are bonus
tests because people are paid for an
initial set of things so these are kind
of an extra thing if they're paid in
this case
um and then the other thing that we get
to see is like the each one of the
the
the missions with a bunch of different
tasks uh has a different kind of status
and this is the kind of thing that the
the curator gets to see as well as this
feed with all the content coming from
the from the workers on the ground uh
that again the cure gets to either
accept or reject if if it gets rejected
the the the person on their phone gets a
message that says this needs to be
improved in this way or that way
whenever you reject something you have
to explain why that is um
and so that's a kind of a very simple
way of of um you know giving and
tracking tasks of people who are
performing them on the ground and so
we've used this for covering about 11
different events one of them was south
by southwest again the idea is that you
may want to have an event report of
something that you are not able to be
there or you don't have the
eyes and time to be there and so we
currently are preparing and trying to
understand you know what were what
didn't work and kind of the overall is
um you know one of the things that we
find is that um
it works uh really well for factual
information and actually we worked with
a couple of bloggers local bloggers who
gave us the task of like there was for
example a town hall meeting in seattle
that they couldn't attend and they
wanted to report it in the neighborhood
blog and so they gave us that task and
then at the end we produced an article
like this one with photos and interviews
etc and the blogger came back and said
that was really useful but if i were to
po to post this on my blog you will have
to have this kind of um
like the spirit that i typically use in
my blog post and this kind of uh
contextual knowledge about the
neighborhood like the person that you
took a photo of is this lady who
everybody knows she's kind of crazy and
all these kind of things that the paid
workers or any worker that comes to the
event may not know about and so you know
one of the the challenges here is that
these people at least the local bloggers
were looking more for a
kind of not only factual information but
also this kind of uh the the
the bias that they typically have to
towards writing some of the reports so
we're still analyzing the data we again
i mentioned uh we run this uh over 11
different events in different kind of
communities and so we're still trying to
analyze and trying to prepare a
submission for csw
so with that i just want to open it up
for discussion questions and again you
know part of what we're trying to do is
both understanding what people do online
as well as trying to build systems
inspired by some of these findings
thank you
yeah
the event eventful
um
the eventful um is really interesting um
but i'm a journalist professional
journalist so my main question is oh
this eliminates the need for
um journalists well the way
the way we've been playing so far with
this is that the journalists or the
local bloggers will be the ones
requesting these uh event reports for
them to then
produce an actual report so like as i
mentioned like what comes out of the
report is often a very factual kind of
step-by-step description of what
happened with photos and so on but i
think the role of journalists as a
person who might ask different questions
or may frame these factual information
in different ways it's still valid and
it's still useful so i don't think it
necessarily replaces journalists
yeah
you connect back to your first type of
reporting in mexico where people just
need facts and they need it aggregated
and they want to be sort of anonymous
and distributed in terms of
responsibility so it's
interesting to think about how can you
then
build feed this back to create systems
that allow people to more freely report
and distribute yeah and that's that's
exactly the motivation for so i think
part of what i found looking at the case
in mexico is that part of the reasons
why
people feel okay reporting things on
twitter is because what they're doing is
so tiny like they're just reporting of a
piece of the event and so it kind of
distributes responsibility across many
different people but the challenge again
is that you still have this one curator
who is like aggregating all that so in
some ways you want to relieve that role
from not existing at all maybe so there
is no risk is that a way that we can
kind of crowdsource all these like
little bits of information that each one
on its own is not that unsafe uh but the
aggregate it could be unsafe but then
that's produced by a system or another
set of you know crowd workers that could
you know generate that and that's the i
think that would be the ideal scenario
of a lot of these systems i'm still
afraid of any introducing any of this in
like the case of actual people putting
people at risk so i think i want to do a
lot more kind of tests and experiments
with this before deploying something in
mexico for example
attacked what's the threat model here
like what kind of attacks like
misinformation we have misinformation oh
misinformation um i mean i think it is
so so far this is the kind of more
manual system that people are doing
kind of works
there are challenges with like the ones
i mentioned where uh there are some
people who gain a lot of reputation in
the system and then they start perhaps
using that information for nefarious
reasons uh but eventually i mean a good
sign of that is that that person or that
account eventually disappear
so i think part of the
the i mean part of the solution is to
think about
long term as well as the
to think about the reputation as a
fragile thing so everybody has to kind
of continuously
keep track of the reputation of those
who they're following um
as a way to maintain the
kind of the
the validity of the information and
every single message needs to be
validated by multiple people um i think
there is still risk and i'm sure it
happens like every day when people
reporting some of those things are wrong
or that may not be true um and i think
it's also
the responsibility also relies on the
reader in some ways like as a reader how
much do you want to trust a lot of this
information you know you might make
decisions that
are important but maybe not put your
life in the near just because something
you read online um
so yeah that's not necessarily an answer
but
it's a complicated
respect
yeah so speaking of reputation uh
besides the sort of number of tweets
number followers you know so you did are
there any other metrics that you're
using to basically reduce the reputation
of the
participants and of the curators in
mexico right uh well most of what i did
is what you mentioned and the other
thing that we also did um kind of more
informal uh interviews of people
on the ground to see to what extent are
these people on twitter who have a lot
of followers
who'd right so yeah um so yeah but it
was not very systematic and i think that
could be a nice study to do where it's
like you go on the streets and say hey
you know out of these five tear accounts
do you even know any of them like it's
possible that maybe they just bought
followers right who knows
but yeah i think there is more work to
be done in that regards to see how much
is the reputation online represented
offline
from what i did is very much like
looking at the quantitative data and
also using some of my knowledge and
contacts and and asking people and so on
but i don't think you know i have enough
evidence to support some of that yeah
i have a lot of questions about the
curators but i think my top two
questions one is um do you know much
about their demographics
yeah the curators have a sense of like
gender identity sexual identity
profession etc
they're really i mean
because they are afraid of their safety
their
they don't release that much information
the only thing that was surprising to me
is that out of the maybe 20 something
accounts that i looked at maybe like 15
of them had a name a female name and
actually when i the the one guy that i
was able to interview um i asked him
like why do you think there's so many
women and he's like oh i don't think
they're women they're using names of
women because they're more reliable for
people like people tend to trust women
more than men and that's why um
i don't know just or not
i'm sorry
so that's his theory i don't know if
he's wrong
my second question is
are there so are there any like like
what are the big positive things about
being a curator for the curators like
obviously they're serving this really
important role in society right like are
they getting yeah i didn't show that but
yeah i asked them exactly that like why
did you do this and what do you get out
of it and they were like explicitly they
were very much like oh i'm doing this
altruistically for the good of the
community but when it get when the
interview got to the point of like what
do you dislike about this twitter in
general or what you do one of the things
that came up is they were really
protective of their content so they were
really upset when actually one of the
things that i thought was i was going to
find is that the curators kind of had
their
unified community or a unified sense of
uh like we are curators or we are you
know not killer they don't call
themselves but we are kind of doing this
together it turns out that they are very
skeptical and suspicious of each other
and part of it is that they are really
upset when somebody
claims that they knew about something
before
they uh before they knew so they said
that john posed something on on one of
the heroes post something on twitter and
then mary posed the same thing and then
mary receives a lot of retweets and a
lot of attention of that the first
person john gets really upset and so
they they say that one of the problems
that they found with twitter is that
people can steal information very easily
and so
one of the things that came up a lot in
the interviews was this sense of you
know if i'm the first person to release
this information i should get all the
credit for that and so
that tells me that you know some of the
motivations are also just status i mean
people do that online all the time right
like
karma points in reddit and you know
whatever on other systems uh and i think
they they sense this uh
reputation in general on twitter as a
very important thing for them and that's
one of the main motivators i will
suspect
thinking about connecting the first
second half of your talks from your talk
the second half is basically in some way
about
structuring the news process so guiding
the actions that people take in order to
cr to create an artifact that is better
than the kinds of things that they might
do if they were just uh you know if you
were to throw them at a media wikipedia
or something like that
and it makes me wonder if that kind of
thing could actually apply in
in
monterey for example
where
you want
right now it's basically opportunistic
if someone happens to be walking around
who happens to be using twitter right
then you know maybe you'll get a photo
but you might get a report or someone
who've heard of someone like it makes me
wonder whether the
community could self-organize in a
slightly more
uh effective way if they have
informational goal or needs that aren't
really being serviced yet i think
there's definitely
there's been a couple of attempts at
doing that
most of the attempts i think have failed
both because
the lack of good tools for doing that so
a lot of the attempts have been let's
all create a blog that we can all
contribute to and then submit things
there but there's always this uh one
person that has control over that and
who you know basically people send them
emails for example um and so there is
never this sense of like there is a
document that we can produce together um
and i think that's one of the
inspirations for this but the other
challenge is just in general
um
the reputation of who is starting this
sort of blogs is always question and so
you know with the curators part of it is
that the reputation is kind of fluid in
the sense that if you don't like them
you just unfollow them and then follow
them back and so on with the blog it
requires if people are participating
requires a commitment of like okay now
you i'm following you and i'm going to
contribute to your blog and so on and i
feel like that's certain barrier uh for
for doing that just in general like
there is never a
person with enough reputation that can
call us all this energy around a
particular document um so
the i think part of the answer is
technical but the other part is more
social and i don't even know what the
good solution for that will be are there
informational needs that the community
has that twitter isn't providing to them
is it enough just to know that something
happened and avoid this area maybe it is
yeah
i mean
it is enough but the problem again as
you were saying is that twitter is very
limited to certain areas so the kind of
people who have access to twitter are
just in certain demographics and so on
and so i suspect if you go to like
poorer neighborhoods and you ask them oh
do you ever check twitter for like
saying what's happening here they
probably don't even know what twitter is
um so yeah those are not necessarily
limitations a little more like
limitations of who has access to them uh
the other thing with twitter is that
it's really hard to
um get a view of what's happening in
like the hashtag is an approach to doing
the view of what's happening in the city
but the problem with the hashtag as it
gets more popular people are posting
things that are kind of nice so one of
the things actually the creators mention
is that now people are using the the
hashtag to report to
announce things that they want to sell
like there was this person was selling
puppies and they were like posting
things like oh buy these puppies and
then using the hashtag to do that or
selling a car or whatever and so the
kidders got really upset like you're not
supposed to do that for this so then
they switch to a new hashtag and they
they abandon the other one but then now
he creates this fragmentation and so
there is really no sense of like who
wants the hashtag obviously that's part
of the advantage but also one of the
weaknesses that you know the hashtags
kind of evolve and then spammers find
them and then there's tons of noise
so i think part of it
they would like to have more control
over the hashtag for example if you were
to to ask them yeah
cool
thank you
all right let's thank our speaker
awesome thank you
you